je me sens mal mais je suis maintenant
je me connais je veux montrer ce soir
merci d'avoir choisi tout le monde non
pas en même temps compte tenu de ce que
vous dites dans votre bouquin au sujet
de la concurrence aurait été difficile
d'y aller non non je pu effectivement
jeu oui je suis dur et fuji elle mais il
met le mérite alors vous publié chez
fayard la possibilité d'une île donc
c'est l'événement littéraire médiatique
commercial de la rentrée votre livre
écrase d'ailleurs cette cette rentrée et
les 650 autres romans de la rentrée sont
un peu réduits au rang de figurants non
oui mais c'est pas de ma faute
j'avais dit longtemps l'avant ce que je
publie un livre plus beau là j'ai décidé
de
d'arrêter de faire de la fausse modestie
parce que ça se verrait donc c'est vrai
que mon livre est bon
oui c'est un peu normal qu'ils écrasent
l'entrée oui c'est pas de ma foot va je
veux dire totalement s'est déclenché
beaucoup de lait dans tous les cas non
ben oui mais ça aussi c'est normal on
peut pas on ne peut pas en vouloir au
moins la jalousie est un sentiment
humain que je comprends parfaitement
avec lequel je sympathise ou même et que
je suis toujours prêt à pardonner
alors au delà du phénomène houellebecq
on va parler du livre d'abord le pitch
donc la possibilité d'une île raconte la
vie de daniel qui est un être humain qui
viennent pas vraiment à notre époque un
qui vit dans une dans une dizaine
d'années à peu près oui oui oui avec
quelques légères augmentations de
phénomènes déjà visibles comme mauvais
traitements ou vieux ce genre de choses
ce qu'on a vu apparaître pendant la
canicule de 2003 we will effarante
inhumanité en fait avec les quais dans
laquelle on finit ses jours quoi le pi
l'islamisme est moins en moins présent
vous dis c'est un peu comme le pain que
c'était très fort c'est redescendu et
maintenant pour garder une comparaison
musical c'est un peu comme la new wave
quoi oui ouais bon ça peut déterminer
alors ça peut apparaître bien optimiste
mais enfin c'est ce que je pense c'est
sa main
sa venue à l'esprit en voyant des des
filles très voilé c'est que le but
c'était de faire peur craint un peu
comme le but des pins que c'est de faire
peur aux gens normaux pour 2015 les
filles ont toujours dévoilement fins et
plus décoratif vous dites oui oui et
puis bon tout ça tout ça s'efface pub
donc je parie sur un sur le fait que les
choses se calment et qui est bon par
l'intermédiaire de
de la jeunesse implique envie de liberté
de nous associe alors ce dernier elle
vit donc en 2015 à peu près et sa vie
est lu et commenté
deux millénaires plus tard par ses
clones des néo l'humain que vous appelez
daniel 24 et daniel 25 alors eu en fait
ils ont pu besoin de se nourrir et vivre
par photosynthèse
oui je ils ont juste besoin d'eux comme
les plantes de le seul minéraux et doux
et ils ont beaucoup moins bon à part ça
il ya des il ya des mâles et des
femelles comme les vives sol reliées par
un
bon à l'internet franchement améliorée
et ils ont un entraînement qui consiste
en gros deux mots d'abord à faire des
exercices pour eux obtenir la paix le
calme
l'absence de désir et de souffrances
dont quelque chose de très inspiré du
bouddhisme par ailleurs il étudie la
biographie de leurs prédécesseurs
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils étudient la
vie de daniel 1 pour essayer de tirer
parti de leurs échecs et de leurs
souffrances pour ne pas vivre la même
chose alors daniel hains donc celui qui
vit dans le disant c'est un humoriste à
succès un mix entre dieudonné bigard
pierre desproges
mais quelque chose de pire que tout ça
réuni parce que il est d'un cynisme
total un cirque dieudonné je pense que
c'est pas purement de la provocation
chez lui je pense qu'ils croient
vraiment à la cause palestinienne est
malheureusement qu il est peut être
aussi devenu antisémites du coup lors
que daniel lui les prêts a allumé tout
le monde du moment qui pense que ça peut
être marrant de misogynie affolante
il ya cette fameuse van tu sais comment
on appelle le gras qu'il ya autour du
vagin la femme
oui oui oui mais il est misogyne mais il
est une espèce de
il est toujours sur le fil du rasoir que
ça c'est un bon pro très très bon procès
y provoque mais ça reste juste à temps
il gagne plein de fric
ouais à un moment il rajoute un petit
peu d'anti sémitisme parce que ça
puisque c'est bien alors il fait un film
porno qui s'appelle brut/mois la bande
de gaza tombereaux leur longe et donc
ils essayent toujours de surfer quand
même pour rester politiquement correct
dans le politiquement incorrect
si on cela que c'est une légère
anticipation parce qu'on est
je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle il y
aurait une espèce de carton rouge je ne
sais quoi mais je suppose que le
l'humour qui a déjà beaucoup de droits
beaucoup mais c'est un peu n'importe
quoi vont en gagner encore un peu plus
et lui se moque de tout ce qui
l'intéressé c'est quoi d'ailleurs c'est
le succès ce qui est terrible c'est que
malgré ses dérapages racistes misogynes
finalement il a une bonne image auprès
de la presse il a des bonnes critiques
dont elle dit vous des bonnes critiques
dans le télérama il passe pour un homme
de gauche
oui mais il réussit pas mal aussi de
des gens d'extrême droite vous dites
qu'en fait que le le seul contenu
résiduelle de la gauche c'est l'anti
racisme oui mais c'est vrai que la com
com contenu de la gauche en ont donné il
ya eu enfin on peut s'en souvenir il ya
eu comment dire une société partageuse
quoi mais tout ça complètement disparu
la gauche est devenu libéral
ensuite il ya eu il est resté une espèce
de libertarisme mais c'est fini c'est la
gauche et anti drogue antitabac donc
belle est la seule cause sur laquelle
basse qui font comme des causes un peu
mobilisatrice offert sur lesquels on
arrive on arrive à mettre d'accord la
gauche etc c'est l'anti racisme que vous
appelez le racisme anti blanc oui parce
qu'il ya une sorte de au fond de désir
désir ne pas être blanc faye et cette
culpabilité manipulatrice et un peu
louche mais donc il arrive à sa propre
surprise est encore considéré comme un
homme de gauche et même comme un
humaniste et pourtant les droits de
l'homme et s'en fout il dit quand aux
droits de l'homme rien à [ __ ] à peine
si je parviens à m'intéresser aux droits
de ma que oui c'est un type finalement
qui a écrémé dit vous tous les créneaux
porteurs le racisme la pédophilie la
torture le cannibalisme le parricide
avec un certain succès donc oui et à 47
ans il est complètement lessivé on peut
plus le type les consciences de
conscience de sa propre médiocrité où il
a conscience d'être un de [ __ ] quoi être
d'être plus d'être plus habile de pas
alors il a 47 ans il est lessivé vous
dites la vie commence à 50 ans c'est
vrai à ceci près qu'elle se termine à 40
quoi donc à 47 il aiguille il est bon il
tient y tient limite quoi enfin ils
l'ont il en a marre de ce qui fait ils
en aient marre de son public qui
supporte plus le rire ce qui est quand
même grave pour un comique c'est c'est
vrai qu'il ya quelque chose de méchant
dans le rire et moi c'est que j'ai
déclaré c'est vrai que j'avais beaucoup
été impressionnée par quelqu'un qui
était naturel chaleureux ouvert et qui
avait connu de funès et on lui demande
de parler de de funès voit son visage
change et légumes dit ah oui lui les est
vraiment triste et c'est impressionnant
parce que de finesse et le comique le
plus gentil le plus tout public qu'on
puisse imaginer
il semble bien que quelqu'un qui arrive
qui arrive à être comique celle qui
s'est mécaniquement comment on peut
faire rire les gens qui a trouvé
subissent ce secret là ce soit un secret
triste parce que là on est obligé de
très bien connaître la nature humaine
oui on oblige est très bien que la
nature humaine et on s'interdit
d'exprimer tout événement peut être vu
comme comique ou comme tragique caution
lui aussi interdit d'exprimer le côté
tragique et apparemment se finit par
vous rendre volume très triste alors
donc lessivé il se retire en espagne
dans une maison de 27 pièces au nord
d'almeria mais tient pas du tout compte
de la beauté du lieu ça au cas sauf
qu'un effet sur lui
e
il s'aperçoit que ça suffit pas que le
lieu peut être beau mais n'y peut rien
en faire on fait de cette de cette
beauté il dit à un moment donné que s'il
avait un réel tempérament artistique il
pourrait faire quelque chose cette
beauté des tableaux je ne sais pas
connaissez pas le cas un nom qui
s'ennuient et il vit donc avec isabelle
qui est une rédactrice en chef d'un
magazine de mode qui s'appelle lolita
voilà 1100 nuit parce qu'il n'a pas
envie de faire des enfants un nom il a
pas envie de faire des enfants et il
n'est pas pourquoi parce qu'il ne pas
imposer finalement à d'autres êtres le
calvaire d'une existence terrestre ya un
passage où c'est vrai je me suis moi
même posé la question pourquoi les
pourquoi les bébé hurle aux points alors
ça arrive pas du tout
aux bébés chats chiens et un cochon et
je pense qu'il ya un défaut quelque part
peut-être c'est une erreur de perdre les
poils
enfin je sais pas mais bon là ça c'est
le côté la science fiction commence à
arriver ici quelque chose qui va pas
d'hellemmes pas les enfants ils disent
l'enfance est une sorte de nains vicieux
d'une cruauté ine et d'ailleurs les
animaux domestiques en en peur c'est
vrai que l'enfant manifeste sa
personnalité sa volonté de dominer son
entourage de manière violente
mais pire que ça au fond sicile eurent
le bébé c'est parce qu'il souffre je
pense réellement qu'on est trop sensible
la douleur que la douleur physique va au
delà de sens de son sa nature de signal
et il ya quelque chose qui va pas au
fond on sent quelque chose de
déséquilibrer dès le départ chez l'être
humain
alors daniel et isabelle ne font pas
d'enfant et le grand événement c'est
quand il recueille un chien un dénommé
fox soir au bord d'une autoroute et là
vous dites c'est le meilleur amour c'est
l'amour inconditionnel parce que
finalement le chien il attend rien en
l'échangé vous aiment vraiment oui puis
et puis ce qui est assez bon tout le
monde toute personne ayant vécu en
couple c'est qu'il n'est pas forcément
facile le rendre heureux le conjoint
alors que le chien c'est possible mais
s'ils ont animé des meilleures
intentions du monde le bonheur de
l'autre n'est pas garanti alors qu'avec
un chien ça peut arriver
et en fait ah ben ça arrive c'est assez
facile de réussir la plupart des maîtres
y arrive c'est beaucoup un
vous êtes heureux avec clément oh oui
parce que je sais qu'il est heureux et
donc j'ai ce pouvoir là ouais vous
rendez quelqu'un fouille
nous devons être heureux alors qu'avec
un enfant ça serait pas aussi évident
c'est pas aussi évident
en plus l'éducation plus facile
concrètement c'est éduquer plus
rapidement alors entre daniel et
isabelle l'amour physique s'étiole
rapidement lui ce n'est au pastis
tranxène c'est quand la faim coltel
parfaitement houellebecq ja oui bon
c'est une vie c'est une nuit
particulièrement dur où il s'aperçoit
que en fait elle aime pas vraiment
l'amour physique j'ai dû jouer ça pour
lui faire plaisir mais elle aime pas la
jouissance parce qu'elle est le problème
d'isabelle dans ce livre c'est qu'elle
est un peu trop noirci elle a été très
très très belle elle encore pas mal du
tout et vous savez les gens qui sont
trop beaux finalement parfois du mal
avec l'amour physique parce que ça les
déforme un chez clyde il est mieux
offrir une image admirait weepu offre
une image glace est calme
la beauté va toujours avec une certaine
froideur quand même et là c'est terrible
pour lui parce que lui c'est ce qu'il
préfère c'est celle là c'est la seule
chose que dans la vie le motive encore
un et isabelle paris la trompe pas c'est
ça qui la trompe pas du tout elle part
parce qu'elle sent qu elle en train de
se dégrader physiquement et précipite
ses propres dégradation pour une
surconsommation 2.3 elle prend 20 kg
provins kg 1
mais au départ c'est elle qui laisse
tomber ouais c'est ça qui est l'art lui
très malheureusement il tombe sur une
dénommée esther nous appeler la belle
qu'à 22 ans et qui va lui rendre la vie
par le sexe quoi on comprend qu'il a ce
monde sa vie où on commence à en vivre
ce qui va être un bonheur total il sait
qu'ils veulent perdre il sait aussi que
ce bonheur est si fort que sa perte
veulent tuer cirque et esther est
vraiment
ils s'engagent là-dedans sachant que
c'est sa dernière histoire alors vous
avez des phrases formidable ali sexuelle
de l'homme se décompose en deux phases
la première où il éjacule trop tôt la
deuxième ou la rive lui a bandé et le
problème de daniel avec esther c'est
qu'en fait ils se retrouvent dans la
première phase en fait il éjacule trop
tôt donc y trouve une crème oui ils
retardent d'éjaculer comptant déjà il
est content de revenir les premières
fois le premier prix est bien sûr bon en
fait nous mais il ya de grands moments
de bonheur dans ce livre m avec le site
est déjà fait il trouve une crème qui
oui on fait des choses maintenant comme
faut pas nier il ya eu progrès technique
ouais pour retarder le régulation et
donc s'en suit une période de bonheur
très intense
et puis et puis là ça c'est violent
parce que parce qu'il est vieux ce qui
est terrible c'est que quand il peut lui
faire ce qu'il veut à cette fille mais
chaque fois qu'il veut l'embrasser sur
les lèvres
elle se détourne un peu commune comme
une prostituée et un moment elle doit le
présenter à sa soeur et elle ne lui
présente pas sa soeur parce que parce
qu'il est vieux donc puis se rend compte
de sa wii face skis ce qu'ils
craignaient se vérifie et puis là bas
quand on est vieux on a eu plein de
soucis dans sa vie en fait plus rire de
vous amuse qu'il peut pas il veut faire
partie de son groupe de jeunes s'est pas
en fait c'est pas le sexe qui ce cas
qu'il casse dans histoire ouais c'est le
fait que simplement il n'a plus
l'énergie la l'enthousiaste ont fait il
est il est trop sage trop troussage même
pas trop résignée trop trop vieux ils
vous dites dans le monde moderne
on pouvait être échangiste bi trans
zoophile sm
mais il était interdit d'être vieux et
les jeunes que c'est le début de sa vie
amoureuse c'est tout et lui c'est la
font vraiment le problème c'est qu
isabelle n'aime pas assez le sexe et
esther n'aime pas assez l'amour voilà
c'est tout le dilemme pour ester l'amour
c'est c'est un divertissement avant tout
il n'y a pas d'implication personnelle
penser que ses propres aux jeunes
d'aujourd'hui ça il est possible que
l'amour soit mort et que ce soit après
dieu ça fait 2-1
oui ça fait beaucoup je sais pas si les
jeunes ont envie d'aimer ou pas je peux
jeune je peux pas me prononcer mais
alors là c'est terrible parce que donc
plus d'isabelle plus d'esther et la plus
que son chien dans l'ombre fox et il se
réfugie chez les elohim it
alors c'est une secte évidemment
directement inspirée des raéliens et ça
vient d'une histoire insensée c'est que
dans la bible
eux s'appelle elohim qui est un pluriel
et qui veut dire les anges
et effectivement depuis de nombreuses
années et à vandaele avant tout vos
rayons
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont dit qu'en
fait le dieu de la bible c'était les
elohim les anges c'était des
extraterrestres bon ça c'est le début
c'est le début du dogme c'est plus ou
moins rendu compte que ce qui était
accordée aux extraterrestres à dire le
pouvoir de créer et de manipuler la vie
les hommes étaient en train d'y arriver
au même techniquement sans sens
extraterrestres et donc la grosse
promesse là hello i meet est en fait la
promesse classique des religions s'est
rapporté à tout le monde l'immortalité
et la jeunesse éternelle
ouais vous dit que c'est une philosophie
très adapté au monde moderne parce que
d'abord une grande permissivité sexuelle
à l'intérieur de la secte et ensuite
elle promet une immortalité palpable
enfin c'est pas une mortalité spirituel
c'est une immortalité physique
en fait oui voilà il n'y a pas besoin de
croire grand chose et deux aides
extraordinaires et s'est adaptée aux
progrès techniques vous dites qu'une
religion c'est une secte qui a réussi
mais vous dites sérieusement ah bah oui
mais ça c'est si on voit les choses
honnêtement si on voit le départ des
religions c'est vrai que ça se présente
vraiment comme une secte c'est à dire un
petit groupe dissident par rapport à une
religion
une grosse religion dont ben al'inverse
on ne peut pas prévoir c'est une
structure actuelle on peut devenir une
religion de grande diffusion
vous le connaissez al oui claude
vorilhon musée sympa oui plutôt et oui
oui vous allez le voir vous avez étudié
oui vous avez vous avez passé du temps
avec les raëliens pourrait faire vote
libre évidemment pour étudier mais aussi
parce que vous êtes intéressé réellement
barça je suis intéressé par les parures
religion en général
et là je vais chercher une secte qui
soit pas complètement grotesque à dire
comme ces gens qui croient que l'oignon
correspond symboliquement à différents
stades de développement enfin quelque
chose qui puisse quand même pas être
immédiatement ridicule et leurs
histoires de clonage lapaska deux ans
ils ont annoncé qu'ils allaient ou
qu'ils avaient réalisés à un clonage
humain
elle a par contre j'ai franchement des
doutes c'est vrai que aussi dit toute
façon on n'est pas loin des rives mais
vous dites toute façon tout ce que la
science permet sera réalisé oui ce qui
ressort du livre quand même un michel
sait si vous avez ni respect ni
compassion pour l'humanité croyait même
une haine de l'humanité et même je
dirais une haine de la part d'humanité
qui est en vous avant vous l'humanité
les misérables et les humains quand on
lit votre bouquin on a l'impression que
c'est un petit peu d des mammifères dans
un zoo dans le fameux parc humain
en même temps ils sont sympathiques
c'est c'est toujours ça il n'ya pas bon
c'est comme dans plusieurs de mes livres
il n'y a pas de y est pas de vraie
solution c'est le désir n'est pas une
solution mais le nom désir non plus donc
passés ces mammifères auquel vous
réduisez les des humains vous dites sont
en quête de sexe de fun et finalement
vous dites à moins de kits dit ce sont
des kits définitive il me serait qu'il y
ait plus que des kits ce plus ou moins
vieux
ils ont que bon ça c'est foutu je veux
dire il y aura plus de aura plus de
dignité à la vieillesse faux pas il faut
pas y compter
ça n'arrivera plus parce que tout ça a
perdu son sens face à reposer sur un
système de succession des générations de
choses à transmettre sa s'intégrer dans
une religion qui chapeautait le tout
donc ça on le retrouvera plus plus
jamais alors ça se vend bien la
possibilité d'une île longue c'est
qu'ils entendaient 300 par jour chez
virgin le davinci code à la meilleure
époque en vendée soixante dix par jour
et amélie nothomb 50 canton quand même
ah mais oui je suis content mais ça
m'effraie un peu le scan and it avec le
davinci code mais bon je suis content
ouais ça se vend bien s'est traduit dans
36 pays
vous êtes déçu par l'accueil de la
presse française finalement non parce
que nul n'est prophète en son pays c'est
ce genre de choses c'est basique mais
c'est vrai enfin qu'on en veuille je
comprends je ne vais pas jouer page ou
bien vivre et vous l'aurez très mais en
plus
ouais vous ne croyez pas que les
journalistes on était énervé par le fait
qu'ils aient très peu de gens qui a eu
le bouquin qui eut cet embargo sur votre
livre bon c'est vrai que si des gens au
bout de trois articles de crise que des
conneries sur moi soit bonne il envoie
une quatrième fois je veux dire il ya
des gens qui meurent jamais ouais vous
avez fait très peu d'interviews cette
rareté des interviews ces tunnels
une façon de vous protéger contre vos
dérapages en vue du prix goncourt
non c'est pareil il ya des gens qui se
coupaient le coup de palu et popi façon
je veux dire si je faisais énormément
d'interviews mlle reprocherait aussi
j'ai l'impression que je suis à un stade
ou quoi que je fasse
mais ce sera d'abord perçue comme très
très mal un rôle à la caisse qu'il force
il fait énormément interview lors qu'est
ce qu'il est fort il fait rien donc
autant que je fasse ce que je refuse
c'est à dire faire des interviews les
gens et qui j'ai envie d'en vous
remercie mais c'est vrai que par exemple
le figaro c'était très dur avec eux vous
avez dit que vous refusiez
désormais tout une interview au figaro
pendant la durée de votre vie littéraire
non menace rien c'est un peu exagéré il
ya eu des mises en cause même pas
seulement de moi parce que moi c'est
aussi le signe évident de gens de ma
famille enfin des trucs que j'ai pas
voici le ferai pas con on est con voici
aussi points et vitré et voir ce qui est
drôle c'est qu'il y avait des publicités
qui était passé dans le point dans
l'express dans le cas où vous avez
annulée si vous avez gardé seulement que
la publicité dans le chien 2008 chien
2000 le message insistait pour avoir un
chien 2005
c'est bien c'est un ami mais pour les
pour les maîtres de chiens c'est la
meilleure revue avait il ya d'excellents
dossiers techniques sûr on est ni au
courant dès qu'il ya une nouvelle un
nouveau parasite offriez un an c'est
vachement bien
sérieusement ça vous fait quoi de pas
être reconnu comme le grand écrivain que
vous êtes michel houellebecq
je suis pas inquiet sur l'avenir du
l'avenir du jugement sur les livres quoi
c'est pas vrai que c'est un
juste un phénomène commercial selon main
ce livre sera lui longtemps
non je suis rassuré vraiment merci en
est heureux de vous voir heureux est
maintenant interdit aux apps haidar
alors michel houellebecq qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter de pire en ce moment
on sait sûrement que j'ai des dents qui
tombe parce que là j'ai un truc
temporaire 1 et 6 à tuer si ça tombe
avant que j'aie le temps de refaire un
truc définitive et je vais beaucoup
merdé dans les lectures ça va siffler je
fais des lectures en public j'adore ça
là quel compliment qui vous énerve le
plus je crois que c'est peut-être quand
on me dit que je suis gentil quelle est
la qualité que vous regrettez d'avoir
assez sûrement l'impossibilité de mentir
parce que moi ça m'a alors le carrément
littéraire moi ça m'a qu'est-ce que j'en
ai bavé dans les émissions où il en est
sommé de dire son avis sur le livre des
autres on pense du mal c'est horrible en
écrivain pardonne ou jamais 1 comme de
démolition public
quel est le talent que vous avez mais
que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir longtemps
je me trouve trop intelligent et je
mettrai à dire que j'envisage trop de
possibilités quoi quels défauts
aimeriez-vous avoir eu je sais pas s'ils
sont des faux j'aimerais bien plus plus
primaires plus instinctif plus immédiat
on dit que vous êtes radin c'est vrai
que non ça je crois que c'est pas vrai
ouais je sais pas pourquoi on dise aux
avions simplement de me rappeler ce que
vous dites que c'est pas vrai qu'ils ne
voudriez vous pas avoir comme fans
j'aimerais pas tellement avoir brillé
comme juan bon ça me ça m'inquiéterait
bon le nouveau roman vous en pensez quoi
ensuite la merde ouais carrément canon
il ne restera rien par qui aimeriez-vous
être détesté b j'aimerais bien que les
écologistes répondait mais agression
permanente
j'aime pas tellement le
la pensée écologiste ça me dégoûte un
peu mais j'ai beau agresser les
écologistes s'ils réagissent pas
pourquoi ça vous dégoûte parce que je
suis resté très baudelairien chercher
tout ce qui est naturel ou ne trouvent
rien que d'affreux quelle est la
meilleure mauvaises critiques qu'on vous
ait fait c'est peut-être une critique de
julian bardon sur plateforme way qui a
dit quoi
en gros je fais je fais trop de
concession à l'émotion facile quoi je
perds un peu d'insolence bonnes
critiques
quels sont les défauts que doit avoir
une femme pour arriver à vous séduire
maladroite ça marche toujours moi je me
souviens une vue du bon en fait j'ai pas
j'ai pas du tout sa valise était une
histoire d'amour par la suite mais une
une stallone scott est la première fois
qu elle m'a vue était très ému de me
voir au fond ce que tu as déjà en
hauteur elle renversait carrément la
bouteille de vin sur moi je vois ça
adorable l'était l'an passé mais suit
est bon ce qui a évidemment pas non il
s'est rien passé
mais la maladresse oui qu'est ce que
l'avenir nous dira pas sûr vous ne dira
pas si j'ai été heureux ou non ça
restera indécidable jusqu'au bout
qu'est-ce que vous n'avez jamais dit à
personne j'ai déjà je vais te tuer ouais
parce que
ce que je pense que si je l'avais dit je
l'aurais fait est que j'ai eu envie mais
mais non j'ai l'intégrer l'interdît
morale du meurtre était le plus fort
ouais quelle est la question qu il ne
faut pas que je vous pose et se serait
peut-être qui je vais parce que j'ai
bougé parce que j'aurai des réponses que
j'ai envie d'oublier
en fait j'ai envie d'être apaisé de
d'oublier je crois pas ou je crois
beaucoup au pardon c'est un concept
c'est un chrétien je peux ces chrétiens
mais j'ai envie de vous parler plus à
l'oubli que pardon oui honnêtement oui
ça concernerait votre mère par exemple
ça pourrait milliers d'autres personnes
mais justement c'est les questions n'en
parlons pas merci très heureux merci
beaucoup michel et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu